it's a friday night at fenway as the red
sox have returned to boston for seven
games the sox to battle the toronto blue
jays in a weekend series
so weber trying to keep the baseball in
the ballpark tonight
stay away from ball four it's been his
sinker location he needs to have success
that sinker is the key to quick outs and
he's not commanding it very well the new
leadoff hitter at least for tonight
kevin biggio
3-2 lifted in the air left center field
a well-hit ball that is gone biggio
hitting leadoff takes weber out and the
blue jays jump on top they're not run of
the season for cavamisio leading off as
dan mentioned this the eighth time he's
hit laid off a 3-2 sinker that didn't
sink it just ran out over the plate and
got on the barrel of cavan biggio what a
terrific swing well he has the count in
his favor 3-1 to xander
and walked him
so he's walked the bases loaded
in front of mitch moorland
and he walked him and that'll force in a
run ben attendee to score
and tie up the ball game that is four
walks by tanner roark
there it is
to second one to first
double play
rohark made the pitch he needed to make
and despite walking four in the inning
allows only one run
richard on the move swung on and missed
the throw down on the money the tag got
him
well vazquez came up gunning and after
the strikeout two down i don't thought
ball sunk or not but he struck him out
that's all that matters strike him out
throw him out he's not a very big lead
he's looking back high throw gets him
anyway easily
bottom two tied 1-1 verdugo hitting 258
his first red sox home run came on
wednesday he'll go after that one and
drive that one high it's deep to left
and that ball's gone
well there's number two he didn't wait
very long to hit his second we haven't
really seen the kind of power obviously
he hit a home run last game but we
haven't seen the opposite field power
look at this split finger and it goes a
long ways this ball is crushed this ball
goes into the seats
easily
into the monster seats that is a great
sign for him boat reached on an air his
first time up
hold fair and it will get down into the
left field corner
biggio is on his way to third
biggio is on his way home and there
won't be a throw he'll score standing up
on a double by bichette and the blue
jays have tied it
boguard support with one out for mitch
moreland there's a high deep drive to
right field by moreland sailing and gone
down into the tunnel mitch strikes for
the fourth time this season red sox with
their second home run of the ball game
just a matter of time before somebody's
going to do damage talking about
mediocre fastballs that he's been
getting away with and you just don't
want to let this guy get off the hook
and mitch did not
is on deck
a little tapper charging debras on the
bare hand guns oh he made a terrific
play and he cut him down one of the best
plays he's made this season doesn't get
any better than this for devers this is
as good as you can make a play coming in
on
put a star on that one that's the
toughest play one of the toughest plays
a third baseman has to make charging
hard go to the bare hand across the body
across the diamond and throw a strike
grew has walked tonight he's both for
one grounded out in the first
line to right center field that ball is
down and we'll get to the fence
teles is on his way to third and he is
going to round and try to come home and
he'll score and then vladi is thrown out
trying to go to third well that's a big
mistake right there you make the first
out of an inning at third base after he
hits a double then makes it a one run
game and the blue jays have had a couple
of base running mistakes tonight and
when you're scuffling the score runs man
you just can't make these mistakes
aj cole back out for the bottom of the
eighth inning
fastball right over the outside corner
one down well what a good pitch by cole
everybody knows he's got a great slider
and it looked like jd martinez had that
slider in his mind but there's a
four-seam fastball and he hits that
outside corner so jd martinez strikes
out for a second time
the 3-2 again
and he got him what a great job by aj
cole tonight had to work really hard to
get his outs with a couple of draw
pop-ups but kept getting the job done
and verdugo will lead off the inning
alex with a home run in the second into
the monster seats
that ball is hammered that's a high fly
ball twisting deep deep deep god
berdugo strikes again
well that's the way to add on and get
some wiggle room a blast
deeper than the first one also to the
opposite field and the red sox lead it
five to three this kid's starting to get
off now the third home run in two days
and you talk about two home runs over
the green monster this is a high sinker
really he gets on top of this thing and
drives it way back this is not a cheapie
here
brandon workman out of the bullpen for
the fifth time with a 225 era the sixth
red sox reliever tonight
this is a high fly ball driven deep to
right
gradual back to the pen
leaps up he caught it
he caught the ball he took it back
[Applause]
what a night
oh is he loving that he's doing
everything right now hitting home runs
playing a little defense gets back to
the wall braces himself times his lead
and pulls it back in and is he loving
that play
he keeps playing like this he's going to
fast become a fan favorite that one's
popped up racing out now coming in ben
attendee makes the catch and the red sox
win it
5-3 the final score workman locks it
down
an array of red sox pitchers seven of
them do the job and so does alex verdugo